Into The Woods is an adaptation of Stephen
Sondheim & James Lapine’s Tony Award-winning
stage musical which blends a bunch of Brothers
Grimm fairy tales and throws an original story
into the mix for good measure.
The classic fairy tales that get a modern
twist are Cinderella, Jack And The Beanstalk,
Little Red Riding Hood, and Rapunzel.
While the new story that links them all together
follows a childless Baker and his Wife as
they try to reverse a curse placed on them
by a wicked witch.
I love a good musical – whether that’s
classics like Singin’ In The Rain, 7 Brides
For 7 Brothers, Calamity Jane, Meet Me In
St Louis and many more; or modern movies like
Chicago, Les Mis, Enchanted, Once or Pitch
Perfect.
This isn’t director Rob Marshall’s first
all-star musical, though his success rate’s
been a somewhat hit and miss.
There was the brilliant Oscar-winning movie
adaptation of Kander & Ebb’s Chicago with
Catherine Zeta Jones, Renee Zellweger and
Richard Geer.
Then there was also the not-quite-so brilliant
Nine, which was even more star-studded and
featured Daniel Day-Lewis, Kate Hudson, Judi
Dench, Marion Cotillard, Sophia Loren, Nicole
Kidman, Penelope Cruz, and Fergie from the
Black-Eyed Peas.
But Marshall’s musical experience doesn’t
end there: he won a Primetime Emmy for his
choreography on the TV movie of Annie, which
he also directed; and he’s choreographed
movie musicals including Victor/Victoria with
Julie Andrews, and stage musicals such as
Cabaret.
So, basically, he’s got movie musical form!
I've not seen the original stage version but
it’s been rather controversial that Disney
was adapting this musical, especially in terms
of what they’d cut and whether the musical’s
tone would suffer.
It’s already getting awards nominations,
including the Golden Globes.
The movie gets you right into the fairy-tale
mood from the start, as it kicks off with
the line ‘Once upon a time, in a far-off
kingdom….’
The line’s spoken by an unseen James Corden,
who plays The Baker.
We hear his narration here and there throughout
the film, though the voiceover’s never over-bearing
as it’s used sparingly and fits neatly with
the fairy-tale setting.
The Brothers Grimm fairy tales and Sondheim’s
musical are both pretty dark, and although
this is a PG movie from Disney, it still manages
to stay on the dark-ish side.
Ok, so, it’s not Tim Burton’s Sweeney
Todd, which had an 18-certificate in the UK
and an R rating in the US.
And I kind of wonder what Tim Burton would
have done with this material.
Anyway, in this Into The Woods, you don’t
actually see any violence or bloodshed on
screen, with the camera cutting away before
anything nasty happens.
But while things aren’t necessarily shown
on screen, they’re not left totally to our
imagination either as it’s pretty clear
what’s going to happen.
So, although the violence doesn’t feature
explicitly on screen, the movie still feels
suitably dark.
Mixing together characters from separate fairy
tales makes for some intriguing interactions
and some lovely comic moments too, with some
particular stand-out parts in early scenes
between Little Red Riding Hood and The Baker
in the woods.
The only characters I felt were a bit on the
bland side were Rapunzel and her Prince.
Neither’s given an awful lot of screen time
and neither has much to do when they are on
screen.
And there’s a thread in Rapunzel’s story
that’s kind of just left hanging.
Having said that, Rapunzel’s Prince does
have a very funny scene with his brother Prince
Charming, and he gets to deliver a nicely
comic line to Rapunzel a little over half-way
through the movie.
As inventive and witty and clever as Stephen
Sondheim’s songs are in Into The Woods,
they very much exist within the setting of
the musical.
I mean that they’re not really the kind
of tunes you’ll find yourself leaving the
cinema singing, whistling or humming as you
go.
As for the look of the movie, sets, costumes
and most of the effects, I really can’t
fault the behind-the-scenes crew!
Into The Woods certainly boasts a star-studded
cast!
Meryl Streep is just fabulous as The Witch.
That she can sing is no surprise now as we’ve
seen her sing on screen in the full-on musical
Mamma Mia!, Postcards From The Edge (‘You
Don’t Know Me’), and in Robert Altman’s
A Prairie Home Companion.
Just as you’d expect from actress of Streep’s
calibre, she really makes you believe her
witch – she acts, sounds and looks the part.
Costume & make-up look incredible – bluey-grey,
matted hair, crooked blackened teeth, stooped/bent
over, thick long yellowed fingernails, & an
ashen face covered in wrinkles.
And she's been nominated for Best Supporting
Actress in a Musical or Comedy at Golden Globes.
Anna Kendrick’s really got the musical mania,
hasn’t she?!
What with movie musicals Pitch Perfect 2 and
The Last Five Years both out in 2015, that
woman just can’t stop singing!
And she really hits the right note as Cinderella.
Lovely attention to detail on her costumes,
whether she’s in her scrubbing-the-floor
outfit or kitted out in a golden dress for
the King’s Festival.
Chris Pine gives a cracking performance as
Cinderella’s Prince, really capturing his
vanity and arrogance in a lovely comic turn.
He’s already flexed his comedic muscles
recently in Horrible Bosses 2 where he put
on an hilariously unhinged show.
And he gets to develop that in Into The Woods,
with some lovely scenes with his brother who’s
simply called Rapunzel’s Prince.
Look out, in particular, for the song “Agony”
where they desperately try to outdo each other!
Emily Blunt reunites with Her Devil Wears
Prada co-star Meryl Streep in a rather different
role though she’s still treated pretty poorly
by Streep’s character!
She plays The Baker’s Wife, who’s dying
to have a baby, but hasn’t been able to.
If you’ve seen Blunt in anything from Looper
to The Five-Year Engagement or The Young Victoria,
you’ll know she’s a fantastic actress,
but did you also know she can sing?
Well, she can, and very well too; thank you
very much!
In fact, this isn’t her first time belting
out a song on screen – she actually won
a Golden Globe for her role in a BBC drama
called Gideon’s Daughter, where she also
has to carry a tune.
Anyway, I love her in Into The Woods for the
same reason I love her in just about any role
– you always believe her in whatever she’s
playing.
Nomd for Best Actress in a Musical or Comedy
at Golden Globes.
James Corden is great as The Baker, portraying
his character with ease.
You may know him for writing and starring
in hit British comedy Gavin & Stacey.
And, of course, he’s going to be replacing
Craig Ferguson as host of The Late Late Show
in 2015!
Again, this isn’t his first musical venture
– he starred as amateur opera singer and
Britain’s Got Talent winner, Paul Potts
in the movie One Chance; and going back to
the late 90s, he played the lead singer in
a boy band in the TV comedy Boyz Unlimited,
which was co-created by David Walliams and
Matt Lucas.
Johnny Depp puts in a brief appearance as
the lascivious Wolf.
Depp’s no stranger to Sondheim musicals,
having starred in Tim Burton’s movie version
of Sweeney Todd: The Demon Barber Of Fleet
Street.
And he’s also worked with Into The Woods
director Rob Marshall before, on the 4th Pirates
Of The Caribbean movie, On Stranger Tides.
But I’ll try not to hold that against him!
I love the understated way they’ve styled
his wolf – he’s got a fedora hat with
little ears poking out, a 1940s-inspired grey-blue
furry jacket over a similarly-coloured shirt
and tie, bushy eyebrows and moustache, and
a tail!
I love the matter-of-fact interaction between
his Wolf and Red Riding Hood – it’s all
so perfectly natural when they meet, ‘Good
day, young lady,’ ‘Good day, Mr Wolf’,
which adds to the humour.
Christine Baranski plays Cinderella’s Stepmother.
Again, she’s got musical form – she worked
alongside Meryl Streep in Mamma Mia!, with
Into The Woods director Rob Marshall on the
movie Chicago; and she’s starred in various
productions on stage.
Though she doesn’t have a lot to do in the
movie, what she does she does very well.
As far as Rob Marshall’s movie musicals
go, I still prefer Chicago.
But Into The Woods is an enjoyably dark tale
with a sense of humour, great performances,
and gorgeous sets and costumes.
4 out of 5 flicks!
What did you think of Into The Woods?
Have you seen the stage musical?
How do you think the movie compares?
And what’s your favourite movie musical?
Let me know in the comments below!
Don’t forget to like this video & subscribe
for more my weekly reviews and interviews.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!